I went to a friend's house for the first
time and we had a good time we had a
good time together in his house for the
first time plus one of my favorite
things is I love seeing how people
decorate their homes you know I mean
that first time over there get a little
glimpse into their personalities what
they're into like oh is that a Beatles
poster who you like the Beatles
but my buddy didn't have any cool stuff
he didn't have like a framed photo of
him in Egypt using perspective to make
it look like he's picking the Sphinx's
nose em I gave me my riot are you all
right I want to pick the god cats
boogers
you had nothing like that his walls were
covered in boring plain mass-produced
crap art like a watercolor of a
lighthouse really you're 28 what is this
the Holiday Inn that piece of crap
bolted to the wall you unoriginal
bastard I'm not making this up he even
had a Monet in his bathroom not a real
Mona no nobody's in an auction like 4
million so nice i'ma hang this where I
poo
but he had a print of a Monet you know
like you see in every doctor's waiting
room ever it'd be fun to go back in time
and explain that to the real Monet
society you know in the future when
people see this with the dots in the
bridge and the dududuu they're not gonna
think about transcendence or elegant
beauty they think in gee I hope it's not
crabs that's your legacy but here's the
thing what you hang on your walls is an
opportunity to show people who you are
so have some fun with it do it do it
right
put some stuff up there expose yourself
that did not come out right I know I'm
not rephrasing it expose yourself
full-frontal creativity get it out there
it doesn't have to be fancy like in my
apartment over the couch I got a big
print of Ryan Gosling thank you so much
and it's not like a sexy Gosling it's
not like an eight foot by six foot
painting of him shirtless with his thumb
in the belt loop just like only at
jcpenney invited holida it's not like
that not that I wouldn't be completely
into that the princes of Daddy Goss I
come daddy Gus in a scene from the movie
drive just right over the couch so when
people come over I go you want to sit
under the Gosling you get more yes as
the notes and you could hate you could
be like peek come on you're 35 year old
man what is this a college girls dorm
room yeah a college girl who majored in
kick ass wall decorations
with a minor and information technology
you know to fall back huh this is what
I'm saying don't just put crap you
bought in the basement of Ikea on your
walls like thousands of other people get
creative go to a thrift store and buy 25
old-timey photographs from the 1950s for
two bucks boom instant conversation
piece right on your fridge just like
look these eight you're all just smoking
different time the fifty it doesn't have
to be fancy or expensive go on Etsy all
the local artists sell stuff on Etsy log
on make some artist day just at home
like huh right how good was that feel to
check your sales and be like I know it I
told you someone would buy my sculpture
of a potato smoking a cigarette Jim I've
been told you and you get a fun smoky
potato or just make it yourself anybody
can be an artist if you play around you
like walnuts just another late-night
monologue you asking the questions on
America's mind you like walnuts sure
everybody likes walnuts if you like
walnuts glue a bunch of a bunch of
walnut shells to the wall like a
thousand of them now you got a walnut
wall
and you're helping boost the profits of
a struggling walnut industry just like
you know thanks to that Holmes monologue
walnut sales are through the roof
suck it chestnuts dial-up chestnuts I
want them to hear me sake sucker
sometimes when we say something positive
about a product sometimes people will
send us that thing to the writers so now
we're gonna get like a burlap sack just
stuffed with walnuts just like thank you
and I know some of you're out there
thinking P what's the big deal I love
going to Bed Bath & Beyond or as I call
it the triple B I buy one of those multi
font at affirmation squares to hang in
my living room boom simple looks good
and I get a daily reminder to shoot for
the moon cuz even if I miss I'll land
amongst the Stars
screw that first of all the moon is way
closer to the earth than any stop now by
a little by like light-years so the trip
will be just sold you a folksy robot
painted lot second the art on your wall
should mean something to you
to you personally frame the cocktail
napkin your wife wrote her number on
don't just hang up a painting of a fruit
bowl do you like fruit bowls does
anybody actually like fruit bowls know
you love the movie the House Bunny so
hang that goddamn House Bunny poster hi
and hang it proud to you baby